Mmm, IPAs. That bold, flavorful beer style
that picks you up, calms you down, and gives
you moobs. Wait, what?
Hello everyone, Julian here for DNews. In
the not too distant past, IPAs were all but
unheard of. Suddenly within the last 5 years
though, they’ve been revived in a major
way by craft beer enthusiasts in the States.
My local bars that used to have mostly lighter
lagers and pilsners now only seem to serve
one or two, and the rest of the taps are dominated
by hops-heavy beers.
Which is a shame, because I really hate the
flavor and my friends made fun of me for not
liking more manly drinks. Oh boy, turns out
the joke’s on them. First though, a history
lesson.
In case you weren’t aware, IPA stands for
India Pale Ale, so named because they were
shipped to British officers and civil servants
in India back when it was part of the british
empire. It was too hot to brew beer on the
subcontinent, but the trip from England took
6 months and a normal beer would spoil in
that time.
The solution was to add more hops. Hops help
the brewers yeast ferment more of the sugars
in the wort, leaving less behind for other
microorganisms to use. The result is a bitter,
flavorful beer with higher alcohol content
and a longer shelf life.
Now here’s the kicker: hops are the female
flower of a plant. As such, they have phytoestrogens,
which are molecules made by plants that mimic
estrogen in humans. Hops actually have the
best estrogen imitator known to science, called
8-prenylnaringenin
this thing.
Now men and women both have testosterone and
estrogen, but too much estrogen for either
sex is a bad thing. For women it can cause
bloating, swollen and tender breasts, decreased
sex drive, headaches, the list goes on. For
men it can cause gynecomastia, which is a
fancy word for man boobs, or in this case,
IPA Cups. It can also cause erectile dysfunction,
which is apparently common enough among heavy
beer drinkers that it’s sometimes referred
to as “Brewer’s Droop.”
So if you’re like me and tired of your buddies
mocking your aversion to IPAs, keep this tidbit
in your back pocket.
IPAs affects your estrogen levels but if you
like spicy food you may be just fine. Trace
and I explain the connection between spice
and testosterone here.